a haunted house too is a movie that came
out this weekend and it sucks it's not
good review / seriously why am I even
here talking to you guys about this
movie the majority of people who are
actually interested in seeing this film
do not care about a movie review or
rating on rotten tomatoes or IMDB or
whatever anyone might have to say buy
the movie they just want to go and see a
movie in which their favorite horror
films are spoofed and made fun of they
just want to see movie where guys get
hit in the balls a lot and people fall
down slapstick humor and animals get
abused and beaten and lots of language
and boobs and everything just fine
everywhere and one likely racist jokes
and toilet humor that's what they want
to see and they're gonna get that with
the haunted house - and you guys already
knew that I don't have to tell you this
movie sucks it sucks i sat through this
whole movie and did I laugh once yes I
did I left one time and that's it I'm
not saying this movie is meant for me
it's definitely not meant for me it's a
movie that as I said it takes the
various horror films that are hits over
the past year and makes fun of them it's
basically scary movie whatever number
except it's not it's made by Marlon
Wayans and I'm not saying the Wayans
brothers don't have talent I've seen
stuff they've done in the past I thought
was very funny I grew up with major
Payne you listen here you big turd I
laughed that a lot when I was a kid I
enjoyed that movie I even like my wife
and kids I used to watch that show too
I've liked things that these guys have
done not saying they're not talented
they're obviously funny guys it's just
that these movies are so clearly made
for money I mean the first film had a
budget of 2.5 million dollars according
to Box Office Mojo that movie made sixty
million dollars worldwide I mean that is
a huge profit so we're going to keep
getting these types of films over and
over because they can make these
handheld found footage style horror
films or even the horror comedies like
this for next to nothing and they will
make a profit on opening weekend alone
basically every character in this film
is there to make a joke about their race
whether it's a black person or a Spanish
person or a white person there's racist
jokes all over the place and am I
offended by that no I'm not easily
offended person but it's just not clever
or funny and it's so easy it's just
jokes we've heard a billion times over
the course of our lives and they're up
on the screen and
they kind of mix it in with pop-culture
references with various films or music
stars like Kanye West and they make fun
of him a lot or the Kardashians they
make fun of them a lot whatever is
currently going on even if it's a little
bit dated they'll make fun of it because
this movie actually does come off as
dated the entire movie takes place in
2013 there really isn't anything funny
about this film every single character
that comes on screen is there to make it
really over the top joke and then
probably get hit in the head with a
shovel or something or poop okay
that's all you where this movie is you
guys don't need me to sit here and tell
you not to see this movie because as I
said the audience that actually wants to
see this film are most likely teenagers
or kids in school who just want to go
out and have some fun with some of their
friends the problem is the movies rated
R so the main audience of the film that
is actually going to want to go see this
movie can't so that's another thing I
was confused by because I'm not bothered
by all the offensive jokes that are in
this movie but I'm realizing that the
majority of the people who actually want
to go see this movie are either going to
have to sneak in or get someone older to
take them and then older person is going
to want to kill themselves the entire
time they're in the theater the probably
gonna make a profit back in the opening
weekend there's gonna be a third one the
best joke in this movie is when Marlon
Wayans is like the current scary movies
they suck like he just makes fun of the
fact that the new scary movies that are
coming out aren't made by him or his
family that's clever
why couldn't have been more stuff like
that self referential stuff that
actually was clever because the majority
people who goes through this movie won't
even get the joke because as I said the
Wayans brothers have produced really
funny stuff in the past I mean if you
ever watched in living color
that sure was hilarious and gave Jim
Carrey his first start it's just that
now these constant horror spoofs that
come out and all these epic movies and
disaster movies and everything they're
just a giant pile of them because they
are so cheap to make and they make money
because they are spoofing off of
something else that's popular and so
people go oh I'll go watch that other
thing that's spoofing off that other
thing I already saw because I like that
so I want to see someone make fun of it
but all it is is a whole bunch of dick
fart poop jokes over and over again the
haunted house 2 gets an F but what is
the point of even reviewing this movie
you guys probably knew that I was gonna
hate it and not enjoy it but I sat there
and I watched it because this is what I
do there's like a weird thing where I'm
like do I even have to review this and I
know I really don't but I want to so
here I am talking about it sorry to be
the bearer
bad news but you knew it anyway good
news though I have been trying to run a
lot of different promotions with my
channel as I've told you about things
that I can offer you guys for free
because I love you guys because you guys
are awesome and I found various ways to
be able to do that and I found another
way a lot of you guys have messaged me
saying that you are filmmakers
independent filmmakers you want to make
films and I really relate to because I
do - there's a website I've used in the
past called shutterstock.com this
website has allowed me to take stock
footage and images and various videos
and high-def and even in 4k to use in my
films legally it's a really really cool
tool for independent filmmakers and so
many people have messaged me saying that
they would like to improve their films
and learn more about filmmaking that
website shutterstock.com is allowing me
to offer you guys a promotion if you use
Kris for one for as your promo code when
you sign up over there you can browse to
a lot of really awesome footage and
videos and you can get 20% off that
membership I've been looking for
different ways to help you guys and see
if I can do something for you in regards
to that when this website contacted me I
was like that's it that's perfect plenty
of professional filmmakers actually
submit to this website and allow people
to use their stuff that they captured
professionally and that is so awesome
use the promo code Kris for one for when
you sign up it's awesome check it out I
have a lot of fun with that website and
I hope you guys do too as always thank
you so much for watching this review
guys I'm sorry to be talking so much
about this movie but I really hope that
promotion works out for you and that you
guys can find cool ways to enhance your
filmmaking as always thank you so much
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
in the heist